bring in Jim Nantz who called the game
with Tony Romo first of all Jim thanks
for joining us good morning how are you
good morning Dan I'm doing well I'm
still confused myself okay it took you
and when did you and Tony Romo realize
that this wasn't just where we review
every touchdown this was did he actually
have possession well if you were
watching obviously we weren't on it
right away
it took us a little while to comprehend
why they were taking so long with the
replay I wish we were a little bit
quicker but you know that's live
television but you know I is silver this
day you know there's this whole catch no
catch thing it's it's the biggest issue
I have with the rules in the NFL and I
fight it then bring it up almost every
other week I would say that man it's
just so confusing to the fan and I don't
know how you change the language on it I
get it I know what it says about you
know you must survive the ground it
sounds pretty dramatic but it's it
leaves a lot of people really unhappy
and the end but you weren't alone with
it as we're all watching it so you know
I think that we thought that's a
touchdown and you know did he have was
it an athletic rule you know is there
too much replay I think we play is good
listen I mean it's um you know you have
to and there's no going back on that
first off I think you know I think it's
an exceptional benefit I don't want to
go back to the days where you just say
no fee I got an eyeball and call it that
way but what was what was particularly
uh tricky about that last night was that
there was no argument on the field it's
not like anybody was immediately trying
to present a case on the field that it
was incomplete you know there was a
celebration going on the Patriots look
like they had accepted the fact that
they have just driven on them in two
plays of course this also spawns a whole
larger discussion to what happened after
you know the ruling came down from over
on how the Steelers decided to handle
the next the backside of that and it's
you know I just left Pittsburgh this
morning I'm in O'Hare right now just
waiting to fly home and you know anybody
wants to talk about it and it's it gets
back to that play that was so much
riding on it yeah
that you know in the AFC Championship
host site in all likelihood comes down
to a call from 350 miles away and I
don't know how you better the system or
how you redefine the catch but no no
this listening to Pittsburgh radio early
this morning and watching you guys last
night I heard what Tony said with you
and I saw looked at local television
said after the game you know was there
any argument that James had already made
a football move and had already
completed the catch and then in an
efforts have reached the ball across the
ball came loose you know there's a lot
of people in Pittsburgh feeling that way
about today but it's not going to get
changed there's nothing you can do about
it now but it's an astonishing way for a
game that's the biggest game of the year
to be decided how much tougher is it if
it is tougher to call games now as
opposed to 10 or 15 years ago I don't
think it's harder i fact in some ways
it's easier you know we take things for
granted innovation of technology has
come so far and I could even imagine
launching a game today without a first
down marker we got the first down line
well we you know we want we grew up
watching football that way and trying to
create guesswork looking on your
television screen at the far side of the
field and see where the chains were and
trying to estimate on your own
now close your door first I mean
technology and innovation has helped the
game and I don't think that's the issue
here I just think it's a simple case of
the catch rule and you know there's only
three examples are gonna be all-time
cases presented the Calvin Johnson catch
the Dez Bryant that's no catch and then
in this one and you could argue that
well clearly the Calvin Johnson catch
was at the start of the season so this
catching that there are no catch and the
Dez Bryant no cats are the two biggest
ones to come down of all-time with this
language on catch no catch but these
don't all show and that would happen at
a divisional playoff game you know so I
mean it's just such large stakes here
yes the season to be possibly decided by
it yeah that was the point I was going
to make is that I know this happens
weekend and week out
NFL but then when we have the biggest
stage here you know I'm waiting for a
Super Bowl to be decided by something
like this where it's a catcher not a
catch we even went back to the Broncos
Super Bowl against the Cowboys
this was Super Bowl 12 I think Johnson
yes that's not a touchdown today that
would clearly not be a catch today the
Porcha Johnson soaring through the air
and once the land of the ball came out
that would not be a touchdown today by
any means and I mean I can't really
argue with that now but at the time we
thought it was just an off the charts a
dramatic catch but today that's not even
up that's not even one left for
speculation I'm not even sure even new
language retreat would trade the the
outcome of what happened in Super Bowls
well he said Jim Nantz of CBS called the
game with Tony Romo how hyper is is Romo
and I mean in a good way like it just he
gets he probably has so much information
processing but he seems fired up but it
didn't feel that he played the position
that way well there is believe it or not
there's a calmness I mean I know what
you're hearing over the air but he's
thinking very clearly obviously and his
football acumen is off the charts is it
absolute dream to work with and yes he
is very prepared and man he is inside
the helmet really for the full 60 it
doesn't just ratchet up in the in the
last two minutes of the game he sees the
field and he thinks very clearly cogent
thoughts about where where this is
supposed to go I'm not talking about
foreshadowing play calls fact he does a
lot less of that now than he did at the
start of a season it was interesting
everybody you know when I first heard
Tony they thought and he's gonna predict
over twice but I thought it was really
unfair to Tony because he has so much
more than just that he has so many
pitches in his arsenal you know it's
just fascinating to be with him that's
all I can say and I'm loving every
single minute of it he's just brilliant
yeah because there was the play where
the Steelers nearly had the interception
and
you know Tony even said look you can't
get Brady another chance and and we saw
him connect with Gronk three times and
lead him down for the touchdown
I will leave you this when I told the
dance that we should reach out to you
the dance did have a question for you
they'd like to RSVP on your invitation
to Pebble Beach to go to your house to
have wine since we'll be out there for
the Pebble Beach pro-am so took a little
bit of time I hope that the invitation
still stands and they want to RSVP curbs
and we're gonna have a little shootout
at my backyard and my little seventh
hole replica okay we'll play surprises
Oh dad you can't do the show from there
but hmm once you finish you know you're
just steps away from from from the house
and it'll be a great honor to have you
and Dad Danette doing wearing sweaters
like sweater vests quarter unlikely tell
us what to wear because you know we're
not normally dressed up and it's your
house we've got a wife and kids and I
work me I wear jeans six days a week
it's just in Jim Nantz wears jeans
six days a week I do not believe that
for a second
Oh Amy right now you got jeans on
tattered oh I promise you I do well
fatter jeans yes I do okay all right we
just want to make sure that we're
wearing the right thing when we go to
the know you're fine okay there are no
concerns about that listed it's
California lifestyle it's you know it's
open door living we're inside outside
while there's beautiful warm sunshine
cool breezes mmm it's relaxed no this is
this is very easygoing
there's nothing fancy about it all right
I love it maybe boardshorts you got a
wrong guy in a tank Tommy with someone
else
board shorts and a tank top and
flip-flops that's fine I'll I'll you'll
match my safe travels back Jim thanks
for joining us and we'll see you in a
few have you out there Dan thank you my
way to happen and all right that's Jim
Nantz yeah Jim came over last year to
the set one where Pebble Beach pro-am
he had his golf cart so he lives that
close to Pebble Beach then he just drove
his golf cart and he said I would love
to have had you guys over for some wine
and then you know we were like why
didn't you tell I didn't know that
like I didn't I didn't know that we
could go over to Jim Nancy's house and
then the dance this morning we're going
can we RSVP now like it's eight months
nine months later but three months or
two months before we get out there it
feels like an open invite so we'll we'll
have some wine heat now I think he did a
replica of the 12th at Pebble Beach or
at Ono the 7th at Pebble Beach okay yeah
so he he recreated one of my favorite
holes in all the going for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]